and minimus
if you would have walked into my
suburban home a decade ago
you would have found a three-bedroom
house with four toilets and a two and a
half car garage a full basement and two
living rooms and two people who live
there it was just me and my former
spouse and if you walk into my house
right now you may not walk in and say
what is what's wrong with this family
they're a bunch of minimalists we're not
monks we don't live in a monastery where
we're not ascetics either we're not
depriving ourselves we've brought in
only the things that add value to our
lives and so when Rebekah and I moved
out here to California with Ella we
started asking some questions about how
we wanted our space to look we knew that
while we really admire the folks who
live in tiny homes or micro apartments
that really wasn't ideal for us also the
huge suburban McMansion was not ideal
for us either so we found a nice
two-bedroom apartment in an apartment
building that works well for our current
needs and we moved here we didn't have a
whole lot of things to move into the
space and so very deliberately we slowly
populated the space with things that we
needed so when you first walk into our
home you'll notice a pretty simple
entryway a coat rack with a couple hats
maybe a few jackets on it you walk off
to the to the left you'll notice we have
a simple kitchen first thing you'll see
is our junk drawer which ryan has
accused me of being aggressively
organized even with my junk drawer if
you take a look at the kitchen counters
you'll see that they're pretty much
empty that's because the only things we
keep on top of the kitchen counters are
the things that we use every single day
everything else gets put away in its
appropriate place it's a blender or
pressure
or utensils those are all in their
appropriate cabinets or drawers you take
a look at our living room we spent
several months finding the couch that
was appropriate for us trying things out
you know it was funny we first moved
here didn't have a couch for several
months Ella didn't mention it once and
there were several weeks we didn't even
have a dining room table we were eating
on the floor on counter tops or at my
desk
it was totally okay I'm complete in an
empty room therefore the things that
I've brought into my life into my home
they must othman or amplify my
experience of life also our entire
family needs to be able to agree on
those things otherwise we don't bring
them in either so whether it's sitting
in my favorite reading chair hanging out
on the couch with vex and Ella or eating
dinner and our dining table writing at
my desk all the things that are there
they simply augment my experience of
life you can go to my bedroom and we
have a bed and a chair and a dresser and
a closet with some clothes in it Ella
has a good number of toys for sure I
know the average kid in the United
States right now has about 300 toys but
plays with only about 12 of them daily
the thing that we do with Ella we bring
new toys in we try to help her identify
which toys she's no longer playing with
so she can let go of those and also
understand where those toys are going so
that if she gets rid of them she's not
just getting rid of the toy but she's
getting rid of them so someone else can
play with those toys in terms of artwork
and aesthetics the thing with minimalism
is the bones are the beauty by stripping
away all the excess stuff we're able to
really appreciate the most beautiful
things in our life we have a few plants
around our house and out on our patio I
think the furniture itself can be
artwork if it's curated carefully
we don't have a whole lot of artwork on
the wall so we do have a few things that
we really enjoy and usually they're
they're multi-purpose our bookshelf for
example is not only does it serve a
purpose it stores the few books that we
hold on to for reference or books that
we are in the middle of reading but also
it serves as a sort of piece of artwork
a tower of art the plants do the same
thing not only do we have nice plants
but they look good they break up the
space and they add a layer of beauty of
living Beauty that you wouldn't get
without them however we don't hold on to
any of these things too tightly I bring
the appropriate things in in hopes that
we can use them for a long period of
time but also knowing that if they
become inappropriate at any time I am
willing to let go
you
cool thank you gentlemen
how you feeling you good you get off my
hair Sean don't move all right I got
let's do it and minimus